it's not supposed to happen and it is  like this is not supposed to be  happening  I gotta tell you your face you looked so  shocked  what was going for your mind at that  moment it's just the uttermost disbelief  I've ever had in my life Ike especially  in a relationship every day prior to  that Jojo and I were just growing closer  and closer and closer and that was just  following her meeting my family and what  I felt was me opening up enough about  what our future looked like together and  so it it really was a shock for me to go  through that that night and you know so  I think it my face said it all probably  Luke will get the chance to talk it out  with Jojo Tuesday night when men tell  all airs on ABC